I heard you might be working on a movie
so how's that going good I have that
same character on a comic
book right there right um yeah yeah um
absolutely having a great time that is a
it's a dream of mine to be able to to
work on that I've loved those characters
since I was little it's such an awesome
world to be in the script is awesome the
characters are brilliant I'm super
excited I'm obviously very happy now
that the the writer strike has resolved
in such a good way and and and we're
we're you know able to reunite with Josh
Friedman our amazing screenwriter and
and uh and then you know I'm really
hoping for a fair and Equitable
resolution to the actress strike soon
too keeping our fingers crossed but
we're we're we're going we're a snowball
heading downhill it's awesome it's it's
got a lot of momentum it's really fun
just real quick U because I'm not asking
you any spoiler type things but assuming
the SAG strike gets resolved is the hope
to be filming and early next year yes we
are going to definitely go uh in front
of cameras next year um probably the
spring are you London or Atlanta London
Pinewood
yeah I was gonna say I think Marvel's
doing a lot of stuff at that studio they
are yeah it's a it's a great place and
again talk about a wonderful old Studio
like too walking around and imagining
you know Bugsy Malone and and whipped
cream machine guns you know I'm excited
I can't wait one of the things about FF
is you have some characters that have
unique abilities and I would imagine you
have been even while the strikes been on
you've been probably working with VFX
companies to try to develop those you
know what I mean like how is how is that
going to look on screen so how how has
it been going looking at VFX for some of
these characters and finding the way you
want to bring these things to life we've
been non-stop you know uh despite the
strikes yes we've been working with you
know the effects and with production
design and building our world and that's
been incredibly exciting and you know
how do you translate those uh skills
into live action in Dynamic ways um
because some things that work
beautifully in John burn and Jack Kirby
are a little tougher when you're filming
them um how do you make sure that things
are exciting but also grounded in a in a
scientific thing which is also part of
the the Fantastic Four that I love um
and we've we've I'm there's some stuff
I'm super excited about and uh yeah I
can't say too much you know tune in dude
yeah yeah believe me I'm trying to skate
around the line of what is allowed
versus you know I'm not I'm not trying
to get anybody in any trouble um but
obviously people are very very excited
to know when you're going to announce
casting so what can you tease people
about when when do you think fans are
going to find out like information hard
to say like I said we're in the middle
of a of a sag strike and I'm you know
keeping my fingers crossed that they get
a great deal really soon and and we can
go back and then uh once that's resolved
you know um there'll be a plan at that
point um but we you know I can't say too
much but there will be an announcement
at some point I know the internet is is
very excited to find out and I'm excited
to share it I just can't do it yet one
of my last things I love IMAX and the
large screen format and I and it shows
what what Nolan did with Oppenheimer was
just amazing And getting people so
excited to go see iMac 70 how much is
that something that have you discussed
with Marvel being like hey look can we
shoot these sequences in IMAX can we use
IMAX cameras for the whole thing like
how much is that sort of permeated into
your head watching what Nolan did with
Oppenheimer what Nolan did with
Oppenheimer was extraordinary what den
and has done with Dune is extraordinary
I mean the format is immersive in the
best way I love seeing things in IMAX I
go whenever I can um and I think that
the world of the Fantastic 4 would
absolutely lend itself to that kind of
immersive
experience so do you think you're gonna
have some IMAX in this movie or um I I
think yes if I were a betting man I
think I would I would I would do that
buy your IMAX stock right now yeah
right I appreciate that um my last thing
for you uh you mentioned that the script
is awesome uh I think that what is what
can you tease people if anything about
how this film might be different than
previous Marvel films um how are you
spinning the you know what I mean like
what's your take on this and how will it
be different than maybe the other things
that have come before it's different in
so many ways I wish I wish I could be
specific I wish I could say more um but
we are doing things very different from
a story standpoint from an approach to
the film making standpoint that really
fits the material and I just I wish I
could say more I would love to but I
can't um but I I I think it's going to
be unlike anything you've seen before
and certainly unlike anything in Marvel
that you've seen
before